major story in our coronavirus coverage
this specifically deals with
masks and the discussion over how clark
county will handle new guidelines from
the centers for disease control
do we need masks where do we need masks
and
who needs masks they were all questions
today for commissioners hector mejia is
live in the newsroom with a decision
just made at commission headquarters
hector john in that decision made just
minutes ago clark county commissioners
approved going back to pre-pandemic
guidelines effective june 1st
the changes also say that fully
vaccinated people will no longer have to
wear a mask or social distance
except where it's required by federal
state or tribal authorities
during public comments earlier this
morning we heard from people against
face covering summer parents
upset with the clark county school
district for still requiring
masks nevada dropped the mandate last
week after the cdc relaxed guidance
indoors for fully vaccinated people and
dropped social distancing however
businesses and organizations are still
allowed
to have more restrictive policies than
what the cdc recommends
creating plenty of confusion you had
noted that the clark county school
district
you have no jurisdiction over you might
want to know that they're waiting for
you to decide
you should mitigate your losses and vote
unanimously to ban all mass
and vaccine mandates and get your noses
out of our private medical business
the state either requires nor prohibits
businesses from confirming an
individual's vaccination status
people are considered fully vaccinated
two weeks after the last required dose
so it's a major update from just a few
minutes ago
county guidelines basically catching up
with the federal guidelines and
we'll have reaction to the changes
throughout the day live at four
five and six tonight reporting live in
our newsroom hector mejia
8 news now